hi mr o'toole happy new year um
what while we could yes it's true that
tests can absolutely detect covet 19 the
reality though is that it's the
unvaccinated who are at greatest risk of
ending up in icu
and it is the unvaccinated that are
overwhelming you know at risk of
overwhelming the health care system and
in turn it is the risk of overwhelming
the health care system that is the
reason that we're all locked down so the
question i have is why should the
unvaccinated be accommodated
if it is their decision to get
unvaccinated
that is leading to part of the crisis in
the health care system
well you've raised an interesting thing
there stephanie you're absolutely right
the incident rate in icus will be far
greater for non-vaccinated that's why we
have to get as many people vaccinated as
possible if mr trudeau's rhetoric
calling people names was was effective
we wouldn't have that problem
but what we found with omicron if you
actually look
in a total way at the data
is you're also going to have some
hospitalization and a lower number of
icu admission for people that are fully
vaccinated in some cases even with the
booster as we're seeing out of denmark
and other
other studies that are literally
being watched on a daily basis so the
more we can give all canadians tools
to keep the the spread down and to keep
normalcy to life is what we have to be
doing what is crazy
is we haven't learned the lessons from
the first wave we're back to ordering
ppe for parliament hill from china
we haven't delivered the rapid tests
promised almost two years ago on his
doorstep he orders them in the middle of
the fourth wave that's unacceptable so
we need to keep strain off the health
care system as much as possible and
giving canadians communities schools
those tools is part of that